okay even though the show was off for a
few days for the fourth of July a lot of
activity on the david pakman show
subreddit were nearly 7,000 of our
viewers and listeners are now engaging
in political discussion and waging the
battle of ideas respectfully
respectfully a few interesting threads
that I noticed this morning at david
pakman.com slash reddit damage-control
Ron Paul claims staffer posted racist
tweet yet during I actually saw this
during the break there was an insane
picture and meme posted by the official
Ron Paul account that included like
caricatured a black people and Jews and
it was just insane and then Ron Paul
came out after the fact and said I don't
manage my own social media and someone
else did it and it was deleted I
actually do believe Ron Paul I just
don't believe Ron Paul is on social
media I I genuinely don't think he's
posting his own stuff well I was
thinking maybe the staffer also works
for Ted Cruz and is the person who likes
that porn video yeah that's back there
seems to be a trend of staffers just
doing horribly embarrassing things on
social media but I actually don't think
Ron Paul is sitting there tweeting I
really do believe it's like a so years
old is he yeah I thought he was still in
a 7 yeah Ron Paul's not tweeting I
believe this okay
also from the subreddit repeal and
replace ice a better slogan than abolish
ice to win upcoming elections yeah I
actually said last week when I told you
about the winner of Alexandria Cassio
Cortes I don't think abolish ice is a
winning platform for a couple different
reasons number one right now we're
dealing with the 2018 midterms Trump is
still going to be president and ice is
not going to be abolished between 2018
and 2020 and I think that it runs the
risk of alienating voters because it
sounds extreme even if we agree that do
we really need ice is this really a
government agency that we need I think
that there are other policies that you
can make more central to your pot to
your platform that will bring in more
people than abolish ice and I actually
don't think it's good political strategy
to run on abolishing ice you don't have
to agree with me that's where I am and I
think reform ice or repeal and replace
ice is a better strategy I mean it isn't
like it's a radical proposed
right because ice only goes back to the
Bush administration's your host 9/11 but
if it's not a winning strategy why even
employ it at all and I'm not even saying
don't run on it for 2020 when the
circumstances are different I just don't
think that Democrats need it for 2018
and I think it may prove
counterproductive in some places also
from the david pakman show subreddit an
article pointing out that Rachel Dolezal
also known as kechi Diallo this is the
woman who I guess is not black but
claimed to be black a couple years ago
remember this crazy controversy she was
booked and released on welfare fraud and
a number of other charges and listen I
thought from the very beginning that
this was not a great advocate for issues
of racial equality and
non-discrimination whatever her
intentions were in identifying as a
black person from the get-go Pat I just
said I don't I don't even think we need
to care about Rachel Dolezal I just
think we can move forward fighting for
the issues we believe are important
without adjudicating her place within
that it was weird when she claimed to be
black but wasn't and the entire thing
was weird to me and quite frankly I'm
just not surprised to find out that
she's been booked on welfare fraud
someone call it you know trans racialism
trans race yes maybe in a problem we
have to address as a society or
something we have to look into at some
point maybe at some point but I think we
should do it without including Rachel
Dolezal in the broader a conversation
about racial non-discrimination in the
United States and I am pretty mostly
glad that she's dropped out of the
limelight and lastly from the David
Pakman show subreddit Donald Trump
considered invading Venezuela according
to reports one of the most disturbing
and cartoonish revelations of the
fallujah lie fourth break and we're
gonna talk more about that a little bit
later in the program but coming to the
attention of many on the David Pakman
show subreddit I invite you to subscribe
for free to the David Pakman show
subreddit I check it out I check it out
about daily are you on there roughly
baby every day I love seeing the post
about myself but I'm also a very
self-centered person pat's they're
basically for reasons of vanity and self
aggrandizement which is fine because
that
why a lot of people are on the subreddit
but there's also a lot of people on the
subreddit merely to engage in a polite
and respectful political discussion find
it at david pakman.com slash our EDD i.t